KAREL VEJMELKA!
HE'S GOT HIS 36UNDERNEATH THE B.
WATCH THIS...
PERFRF TIMER  IMPROVED THE
POWERPLAY.
FIVE POWERPLAY GOALS IN THEIR
LAST TWO OWN
NET.
MY HEAD, TEN
SYLLABLES FOR A D PAIR, THAT'S
THE GAMES.
FIRST TIME IN 16 CT PASS ACROSS
PHIL KESSEL.
HE SNAPPED IT TCHANCES,
AND THEY DREW THAT PENALTY WITH
OFF TO DRAISAITL DIRECTLY TO
BARRIE. IN RECENT
WEEKS ON THE POWERPLAY.
AS YOU
MAINTAIN THAT SPEED.
BEAUTIFUL PASS TO YAMAMOTO,
-- GOSTISBEHERE.
THREW IT A A ASHE NIGHT
MARKSTROM DID THE
BY STRALMAN.
KESSEL TRIED TO SMACK IT OUT OF
MIDAIR.
cLEOD IS GOING TO PICK U
KOSKINEN THE REACH, COULDN'T
PULL IT HOME AND NOW EVANDER
KANE THROWSEN ON ARIZON ON THEI
AND THEN TACKING ON ONE
THIS PUCK BOBBLES UP.
THAT PLAY RIGHT THERE TO CHIP IT
OVER TO DRAISAITL BY k: THEY'RE
DRAISAITL.
DRAISA
HALF WALL.
YOU'D THINK THE COYOTES HAVE TO
CONVERT THIS IF WAS PRETTY UPSEY
UP.
ARIZONA JUST CAN'T CLEAR,
PULJUJARVI, BACK DOOR, DRAISAITL
ABLE TO TIP IT HOME!RE TOURIGNYA
AND THE TROOPS SHOULD BE